[Music]
nestled in the heart of scenic new
england lies the small industrial town
of southbridge massachusetts
it's home to the vienna inn restaurant
husband and wife jonathan and lisa crock
have owned and operated in since buying
the property back in the year 2000
jonathan had this crazy idea of creating
the vienna
as an austrian restaurant and bed and
breakfast she said
have you been drinking
no not yet
we try to transport people and to give
them that feeling of being in vienna
without having to fly there
when people come in they stay here for
the first time they think that jonathan
lees are a very gracious host charming
the perfect married couple but if you
dig a little bit deeper and you stay a
little bit longer find out it's quite a
different story lisa is an emotional
person she does get upset often she will
just you know explode and she can't help
but be upset
she's over the top
[Music]
my beautiful wife
my boss sometimes she's not so nice to
me why do you always have to dress like
a goddamn like bum
there has been a time where i called her
a psycho [ __ ] because she was being a
psycho [ __ ] clean up yeah
i'm done with this
i don't feel like lisa is authentic when
she's crying i don't feel like she ever
means it
[Music]
jonathan and lisa live in a room at the
end you can hear them screaming at each
other and you can hear it in the dining
room so there's no boundaries they'll
come down after the shift at the end of
the night and they'll have cigars have
some drinks the environment can quickly
become unprofessional she'll go up to a
table and ask them about like their sex
lives you are good looking
we don't get that many locals at the
vienna there's like a lot of things that
people think in town about the vienna
and i think it's become a little taboo
you have those rumors going around
people say oh the vienna they're all
swingers it's a big brothel
it's just it's just ridiculous
it's ridiculous
that being said
we're very friendly people
very friendly
[Music]
people from the outside think the vienna
is doing very well and we're very
prosperous but somewhere in there we're
losing they're dragging us down with
them and if they want us to help them
they they need to help us
the vienna is our home has been for 13
plus years
and
you know it's hanging by a thread
[Music]
and this 5 30 at table 5. you're walking
right in we want to be ready for
this place
my god
what happened to him
[Music]
he didn't last very long did he
we found our cat
oh
bloody hell dead cat and a cabbage isn't
that funny
hello welcome
nice to meet you that was good to see
you too golden first name is melissa
melissa good morning how are you lisa
crock lisa nice to see you you don't
look very happy i do i'm not oh it's my
resting face wow um yes welcome to the
vienna i'm so happy to be here welcome
to the cat
poor thing
cat got run over oh i see and you got it
stuffed
for halloween
right
actually
better to see you now
right um
yeah
i love the attire by the way
thank you
everyone wears this
wow how much are the outfits about 300
400
300
average you know they get their own i
mean they're their own dresses you know
oh you buy your own uniforms yes they do
stop it we do well they have them for
many years and it reminds them to not
gain weight
wow so who designed the place
well um my husband and i and whose idea
was it to buy it
um my husband so it wasn't yours it was
not my idea actually very much against
it wow ah
why were you against it it was very
overwhelming i had two small children
but probably uh after i lost my mind the
first year
i think we started to get a hang of it
and who's austrian are you my husband's
half austrian and polish right i i'm not
nearly as exotic i'm very american right
and he's the chef right
so he runs the restaurant kitchen and
you run the inn correct
and whose idea was the uh violins on the
table mine where'd that come from that
was actually from an estate sale down
the street a dead man's violin
why not
i don't want to sit across the table
with my wife and look at a dead man's
violin well a bit freaky no i don't know
what would you rather look at when you
see the vienna huh
who's her
my wife oh your wife yes but you have to
have something to make up that white
space
what would you suggest
my wife
you going to put her on the table that's
kind of scandalous i am so [ __ ]
confused dead man's violin what about
some flowers
bloody ham is this place always as
clustered as this
[Music]
and who's that there a prussian family
of course that was uh friedrich that uh
their family always murdered
uh
hungry yes wow so dead man's violin
murderer on the wall um great story to
encourage a nice warm welcoming dinner
so um why don't i check in upstairs you
can do that right now yes please
thank you
wow
wow
interesting indeed just a clutter your
bedroom's over here rocking chair
where's that from that's actually the
first piece i ever refinished wow
so you're quite an antiques holder
room service oh room service come in
mackerel now what we have here is some
pulled boar shredded shredded yes right
and then you have a little celery root
right on top wow
and what's that a little parsley
excellent um well
take one
would you like me to have one yeah of
course there's three three pieces yeah
excellent sure
thank you thank you for sharing you're
welcome oh hold on wait wait let me put
a little bit of the garnish on there you
want me to have that but yeah we'll have
a little piece
what did you think of that by the way
celery root really don't like it
the full bore maybe just a bit more soft
wow and what did you think of that i
think it's a nice little surprise for
people when they come in
to uh liven up their appetite
boar was very watery it was very watery
and the bread was soggy soaking wet from
the celery root thank you enjoy your
stay
please pass on my comments to the chef i
definitely will
[Music]
here we go
oh dear okay wow and who designed these
bedrooms i designed everything
you design
i wallpapered it as well
seriously
what's this
that's a another closet
i don't have a closet in my bedroom
that's a closet that we have because
there's an area over here for guests to
use but where am i going to hang my
clothes
right over here
you don't need an entire closet so if
you need clothes out of your closet you
come in my bedroom
do you have the key on you
i do can i see inside i just i'm a bit
freaked with locked doors in my bedroom
oh my gosh yeah i'm sorry
thank you it's right here oh it's there
wow
just my closet
holy crap stop it
stop it seriously all my stuff
there's like a garage sale in a closet
that's why we keep a lock on him i've
got no interest in wearing another
garments but thank you
are you sure i'm i'm positive uh 100
positive bloody hell
what's the price of this room this one
is 220. 220 dollars
crazy yeah
and i have to share my wardrobe with the
owner
but what's through this room here that
actually goes to my bedroom so do you
just walk in when you need to get some
clothes
from here
no but from your bedroom to my bedroom
well i only do that once or twice a week
and what's this
wow
it's an antique purse that was actually
found in the house and we thought it was
really neat to be able to have
that's for that's a toothbrush holder in
case you decide to take it along with
you that's a toothbrush or you could
stick tampons in there if you really
wanted to
we do usually have those oh they're not
in there right now there you go an old
lady's case
i'm just trying to think of clever ideas
to make this feel like a historical
historic
it's definitely historic oh
bloody how how old is that you need that
uh no it's just fascinating to see
what's in my basket thank you for that
oh dear
everything looks dated i mean first
impressions it looks very very tired
what is all that
somebody wants to throw roses on the bed
oh for god's sake isn't that adorable
and then they go back in the drawer i
guess once you've used them
[Music]
okay well i'll uh look forward to seeing
you downstairs i'll have lunch super
thank you you're welcome
well
jesus
that's freaky
the owner's bedroom is literally a meter
away the place is so dated
what a mess
[ __ ]
eric's just cluttered
what a mess
look at this
hey
i mean seriously
bloody hell packed with [ __ ] everywhere
more decorations
terrible
[Music]
let's get some food out wanna get some
cool down yeah
jesus lisa
let's jump everywhere
mm-hmm
yeah i know everywhere
is the whole house packed like this of
course it is
it's crazy have you always been this bad
it's a new thing i'm coming at terms
with nice it's just uh but you do have a
problem with it actually no i i think
i've actually gotten rid of a lot of
things in the past couple years don't
have a problem with everything i've just
seen in the last 10 minutes
here wow go
right let's uh oh geez um do you know
how to say all these how'd you pronounce
that suits god
um you've been here a long time you must
never linger
a lot of people must point to what they
want to order right or just pick up the
last line how did you pronounce that
uh konigsberger clocks wow and how long
has this menu been running like this uh
since the beginning oh 13 years ago
yes seriously yes let's start off with
go for the scallops okay let's do the
beer batter the sauerkraut yeah let's go
for that um and throw the vegetarian
mushroom ravioli in as well wonderful
okay great i'll keep hold of the menu
for now okay thank you
sear it in first
whoa yeah almost lost it regroup regroup
where is missy i'll bring it right now
mr ramsay's first red pepper blanc yes
sir
our seared diver scallops with a red
pepper burblock wow thank you and
scallops are normally round right yes
they are we have beautiful sea scallops
i'm not sure why they cut it up today ah
normally oh well excellent okay thank
you very much looks like the dogs chewed
them i mean seriously
that's rancid
what's up with that one excuse me would
you like me to give me any comments back
to the show comments yeah those [ __ ]
thank you terrible
we'll have val take care of it for you
who's val me i like the way you talk
about yourself in the third person seer
diver scallops tastes like [ __ ] tastes
like [ __ ] really
wow okay
any specific kind of [ __ ] or just no
diarrhea
these here are the
sauerkrautig
and are these edible flowers they are
chrysanthemums yeah
okay great thank you all right
hmm
they are terrible i mean the food is so
dated it's extraordinary
like a pair of camel's bollocks
this i have here is the mushroom cream
taro and cream wow
i mean what a [ __ ] mess
there she is [ __ ] it out wow
wow yes delicious
i mean you're kidding me no no i'm
[ __ ] delicious seriously really good
no the flowers i'm all about ah you had
me going there for the whole second i
thought it was all about the food i
maybe next course jonathan the flowers
are absolutely delicious the flowers
and this menu doesn't change every
decade it's the same menu it's been on
for 13 years jonathan doesn't check
oh sorry i asked you a question at least
always answers you jonathan doesn't
change much i'm jesus i'm sorry you you
answer melissa's question first then
i'll go back to melissa you said this
doesn't change but once a decade and i
said jonathan doesn't change my right
um you've been here a long time you've
seen the place uh in decline and what's
the big issues here a little
disorganization
um things unclear yeah nothing
consistent yeah and you know one puts
the other on edge and we get the brunt
end of it
lisa's listening to every word you're
saying
i i can barely hear you
no no i was just talking to missing
okay i'm sorry ellie do whatever you
need to do
um what's the worst thing she's ever
done to you
uh smacked me on the back of the head
and in front of the customers
seriously
in front of the customer not hard but
still uh demeaning
yeah i'll say
dad
said there was under season
overseason underseasoned
failure which
everything
wow um where's lisa
i will grab her for you right away mr
gordon
and grab jonathan too as well will you
please i will go yeah and anyone else in
the kitchen please okay excuse me lisa
jonathan yeah can we meet up in front
with gordon
that's the most edible thing in here
uh right
um
first impressions now look outside
historic inn
unfortunately you've misspelt that it's
prehistoric everything's so dated i go
up to the room and the room's shoddy
jonathan do you not think it's a bit
weird that a my door's open adjacent to
your bedroom but your wife's clothes are
in my closet
i never thought of it that way but i
guess that is weird
that was shocking
you just served me one of the worst
lunches i've ever eaten and it was that
bad i started eating the edible flowers
you can't be proud of what you've just
served me and charged me absolutely not
you're correct you clearly have given up
it tastes like it and it feels like it
what do you think we should do clothes
because your heart's not in it
and i think your head's just in with the
clouds
embarrassing
pretty [ __ ] awful
it sucked
caught me off guard completely
i mean you knew he was coming
i did
really embarrassing
i really thought we
tried harder
i let you down i'm sorry you did let me
down i'm really sorry
i always try to tell you that we need to
change things we need to make him sexier
if you never want to listen to me
i've always wanted to change and you
always say i'm too random and it's not
i'm not random i'm trying to show you
ideas and things that we can do
differently
it sucks he couldn't have cooked worse
than he did can you pull my ankle it
hurts so much i'm never gonna be able to
walk tonight oh
god
don't worry about it
we'll be fine we'll figure something out
he doesn't [ __ ] listen to me does he
oh i feel so good
i'm not really that upset i'm just
crying because i want to right now
i've heard rumors around town that the
basement is known as a swinger's hangout
and is used for late night parties so
before dinner service i want to take a
look at what's downstairs
wow
look at this
my god
some really expensive stuff this is
crazy i can't believe how much stock
there is here
it's not just spending the money in all
the wrong places
look at that this place goes on and on
oh my god
please shout out before entering the
mineral spa
mineral spa
oh my god
this is like a dungeon dungeon for
swingers
tonight is crucial because i need to get
my eyes on how jonathan and lisa are
running the hotel since both of them
seem to be on different pages can i uh
get your beverages to start with we're
getting some wine okay i was i was
thinking cosmos but mine
there's so much stuff in it i've never
seen a kitchen so cluttered it's been
worse believe it or not
how come the food just sits there right
at the moment our timing is really not
at all good
what are these for jonathan those are
little pre-meals little cracker little
piece of cheese pre-meals
i get that too to get rid of please
uh to get rid of yeah i trash oh you
can't serve that
lots of paper for customers to eat
you can't ask them to dip into a [ __ ]
doily with a cracker
and then a flower again
it's just no it's a bit [ __ ] up joey
it's not your place but it's just a bit
weird
you okay yeah no i'm fine i'm okay when
were the chickens roasted
two days ago
that's the last of them
why do we roast them two days in advance
they're delivered twice a week they're
cooked off the delivery day what kind of
impression do you think you're sending
out to your customers when that
chicken's roasted two days before they
come
when did you think this chicken was
roasted
you wanted my goodness i hope it was
today it was roasted two and a half days
ago
i am not happy to hear that at all that
was gonna be dry as a dog's bone but
anyway uh try to enjoy okay thank you i
don't feel well anymore thank you i was
right
they've been coming for 12 years you
need to seriously just focus on getting
this night done and they sit there all
schmuck i want to kick them out right
now
do you want us to take the food back
i mean this is like so disappointing
that you guys feel this way i thought we
were friends and i i thought you would
have maybe told us if you felt the food
sucked that much you know it's really
gosh i feel i don't feel like i want to
pass out right now [ __ ] you now
um so the lady was just talking to over
there had no idea how chicken was
roasted two and a half days ago
it was roasted two and a half days ago
yeah i didn't know that okay fine it's
not my business with him no i'm just i'm
just god you two are so defensive
there's a thousand different ways to
make special
i've got nothing to do with that i'm
talking about the chicken i'd love to
find out the problem chicken i'm talking
about the chicken
make an excuse again
focus on it nothing resonates with you
does it nothing it certainly does
actually it all does
what
and the hell ah i just wanted to keep it
together tonight
that's all
crazy are you like manic
i'm manic yes i am right now
how's it going guys uh something between
shitty and awful what does it mean when
you feel like an elephant sitting on
your chest oh you don't have a heart you
can't have a heart attack
are you hungry gordon what is this
that is bacon should be on a different
shelf and this here that shouldn't be
thrown there either
what's that you're better for the beer
better shrimp it should be thrown out
and this one let me just start that on
top put it right on top
what is all this
that was
bacon no no no no okay now why is it in
your fridge like this
i dropped it one shelf below instead of
putting where it belongs i put it on the
corner normally these things are pretty
orderly this is a complete [ __ ]
almost
barbie
let's see let's get outside okay let's
go outside
what is going on
the whole operation is screwed the
kitchen shocking the line disaster
cross-contaminated
raw meat cooked me different foods [ __ ]
everywhere and then the biggest asset
where all the money is is downstairs in
the wine cellar
who's maintaining standards here
he is i cannot believe what you've just
done in there
i really enjoy it
you can't enjoy that i do that's i must
be like cuckoo in the header or you need
help maybe he does
you need to wake up
[ __ ] me
i think we can do this i know we can do
this
yeah but
not just you and you
i wanted to be you and i because you so
don't listen to me most of the time like
when i tell you it's time to come home
jonathan it's time to [ __ ] come to
bed and you just say [ __ ] you well you
know [ __ ] you now [ __ ] you jonathan oh
yeah i love you so much and you're such
a great guy but you suck as a business
partner you really suck thanks
do you want to recreate this you want to
clean it please i don't want to get
divorced you want to get tomorrow no i
don't want to get divorced why has it
always been your way i guess i can't you
know more than me apparently i don't
i'm as stupid as you think i am if not
worse oh thank god
let's go in the back door
[ __ ] me
okay give me a drink i couldn't get this
down fast enough
that looks pretty good
all right
[Laughter]
it's gonna be okay
thanks for being on the other side we
appreciate it
oh sorry
that bourbon was really strong
oh
crap
crying again no it's not really crying
it's just releasing release it lisa can
you and him together please
sure
i'm unconvinced
and i've never met a couple so
undeserving of my time and i think you
lisa you're just faking it
i'm just trying to no you're trying to
get through the night tonight no you're
acting the crocodile tears are there
next minute is a laugh
it's self-preservation and it's the only
way for me to get through the day
there's no heart there's no fear there's
a lot of heart no there's no
i love what i do and what do you love
drinking with your friends i don't do
much drinking
i'm not the party girl he's the party
boy so there's no parties way on after
service downstairs in the basement with
the customers not in the past like 10
years
jonathan you've lost interest
i'm a mess yeah you are
so the first thing i want you both to do
is to pack a bag
i want you to get out of
here start packing
after sending lisa and jonathan away for
the night i'm hoping they can start to
realize the effects they are having on
the vienna
but before they return i called a staff
meeting
morning good morning
so i can get a better understanding of
the damage that lisa and jonathan are
doing
i didn't get a chance to meet you
yesterday um jamie do the housekeeping
here okay great let's get one thing
right i'm here to help having done my
research i mean the one positive
feedback i've had is about how good the
staff are because i know you know just
how bad things are and having witnessed
that service last night uh i'm appalled
is it always like that yes
screaming yes yes
you can hear them in the dining room
i've had tables that have asked um if
everything was okay in the kitchen we
can't be expected to be professional all
the time when they're not professional
after our shift they'll sit down with a
table and expect us to wait on them hand
them drinks until midnight if we leave
they get upset so guests stay here and
they're drinking downstairs in front of
those guests sometimes with the guests
yeah see there's no separation between
business right yeah and personal when
you're sitting here entertaining your
table she'll find something wrong that
you're doing and she'll come and point
it out at you right in front of your
table
she's just rude she texted me sometimes
really rude text messages like oh you
forgot this or you forgot that or why
didn't you do this and why wasn't this
nice this is crazy another problem that
we've really been having is we don't
have an actual payroll system there's no
payroll and then he'll say yeah i'll get
you one and you're just never
asking for your salary we have yes we
have to ask you for a chance yeah i got
i got 20 bucks right now that's all i
got right now here
tomorrow morning i'll see you they're
drip feeding your salaries my bank does
not take the checks neither does mine
when was the last time you had a staff
meeting and discussed this never never
uh i'm sorry but i want to put an end to
all this
is what we're gonna do
um they're arriving any minute now
and my message to them is if they're not
prepared to bring in a level of
professionalism and understand those
boundaries need to be met on a daily
basis they're going to lose the in
and they're going to lose you let me get
them
[Music]
i let myself continue to be abused they
need to know that it has to change
and it can't just be brushed off anymore
[Music]
i have a chat with the team they're not
in a good place
and you've abused them there are no
boundaries they're your staff
and they need to be treated
a certain way
let's go to jamie first
i'm really concerned about the abusive
text as you send him
why would you send him an abusive text
oh you would send me a picture like oh
you forgot this or you didn't do this
right you told me that you worked at a
lot of other places and you knew how to
clean and i knew the toilets aren't
cleaned and stuff it's really important
but some of that stuff doesn't work so
it's like i'm sitting there scrubbing
and nothing's coming up and you'll be
like well go do it again
and it's like
i'm trying i'm trying to do what i can
none of these talent individuals get
paid on time
i want to know why they don't get paid
on time
because i don't have a payroll system in
place right now well that's a [ __ ]
disgrace
that is disgusting
and then you want them waiting on you up
until all hours of the early morning
while they tidy up after your crap and
then you can't even be bothered to pay
them on time it's a
it's a mess no
you are a mess
i need to say something though that
almost every single person here we've
given them loans you're lending them
money to buy uniforms that work in your
goddamn business right that's absurd why
why absurd to pay for a uniform the
business should be providing the uniform
maybe we need to do that yes i never
thought about it that way whose business
is this
i've tried to create here a place where
people can come
and and
[Music]
and relax and escape from their
stressful lives escape from their
stressful lives to hear you and lisa
scream at each other
are you [ __ ] kidding me
we don't always scream at each other but
well when we do i'm that's what's going
on the smallest places you live here so
you've got no idea how many times you do
it
the love
affection and respect that they've shown
you is extraordinary
and the sad news is
you both don't deserve it
i'm sorry
i will change i just hope you you guys
want to continue
i just want to say thank you for your
honesty uh
loyalty uh
there's some other important people i
want to introduce you to this morning
thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you
guys
uh good morning ladies and gentlemen
good morning
uh so lisa and jonathan uh i've asked uh
some
ex-customers uh locals to come and give
you some feedback
has anybody stayed there recently we did
the room we stayed in it had tools and
screws and instruction manuals
so it's not just for the air
conditioners and stuff yeah that's right
you're right madam give us an insight to
your experience please i do have to say
my husband ordered uh scallops and they
were raw
we returned them
the decor was very outdated and it feels
very cluttered you feel like you're
locked in a closet it's just
overwhelming when you're trying to have
a nice dinner i would never come back
there if things don't change
okay
what do you guys think about the
uniforms it's a bit the poor ladies were
kind of revealing
our server was the nicest person but i
think it takes a lot away from them it
doesn't need to be in your face
the reputation locally
is crucial what have you guys heard i've
heard that's a swinger's hangout
i heard that as well when i had
mentioned the vienna they said that's
where the swingers go
you eat downstairs and then you go
upstairs is what i was told
but you've heard this before
we've heard it
you've heard it for 13 years but is this
due to your late night drinking and the
partying i don't think so fact or not
that sounds like yeah
you're living there but what i'm trying
to say is that there are no boundaries
it's a oasis down there that has got a
jacuzzi a massage table
and if the word has gotten out around
town
and then people misunderstood that room
and that's where it all started i'm just
saying it either a business
oh it's your home there's no there's no
crossover the mixed messages you're
sending
is your own fault
because you haven't been clear
i used to come to the restaurant
probably every month or so
and i can tell
you have a lot of like passion for your
heritage but
it's not in the food anymore
if gordon can help you take your
heritage and the food and modernize it
and you can progress with that i'll come
every friday mark my words it's a
promise
do you have anything to say both of you
to these yes
thank you so much for your honesty and
input and
uh really really appreciate it we're
going to be making some big changes to
uh address many of the things you talked
about
the staff
have been incredibly loyal
they haven't been treated the way they
should have been treated i'm undecided
about these two but i am committed to
that team because i see what is at stake
and the jeopardy they face going forward
now
i got some
something else important to sort out
after leaving jonathan lisa i moved
forward with my plans to help renovate
the inn
i brought in some elia dave foss to
create a beverage program just have a
look in here i mean that one's fantastic
from the excessive inventory they
weren't using oh three oh that's
delicious my team worked up to the last
minute
transforming the many spaces at the
vienna wow
wow that is amazing holy smokes
this is beautiful this is incredible
bravo
the vienna had no organization for
managing their day-to-day operations
so i gave them the state-of-the-art
system to help with all their hotel
operational needs welcome to the web res
pro system and this will help transform
your business it will link up to the pos
system and it will give you data like
you've never had before that was
you need to be organized
from the infantries
to the wage costs to the salaries to the
pos systems to the checking in and the
checking out system
and the good news guests can now book
online so this
should
relieve a huge headache
i could see that everyone was thrilled
with the changes at the vienna good have
a good look round but as i watch lisa
where's this stuff from
i noticed she was dissatisfied with the
renovations these are different chairs
from the other ones aren't they no
i was just seeing if it was 100 cotton
it is
is that a pull out no it doesn't need to
be a pull out and right now i'm worried
where lisa's head is going into
re-launch this evening
[Music]
good evening i can help you with your
bags but first let's get you checked in
while it was time to relaunch the inn
and restaurants
yep we have an art i provided the staff
with brand new uniforms that go with the
new updated menu that includes wine
pairing and beer flights
first is going to be the grapefruit then
the second is going to be the pilsner
up here please get out of here lisa off
the line
actually let's turn this lamp on
no light bulb
oops
excuse me you see jamie uh no light bulb
in there i just wanted to don't worry
about it okay who's complaining about
the light bulb oh just making sure that
they have enough light trying to turn it
on then realized it later doesn't matter
it doesn't matter let's focus on the big
things are you always like this over
little details like that i like to have
things feel right and so
i'm feeling extra like an extra need to
make sure everything's right that's all
ott
probably whatever that means over the
top
well over the top i guess i don't have
to be so over the top now do i you do
not
what is wrong with her tonight do you
think she's gonna go back to her old
ways when i leave she might accidentally
customer's coming welcome while lisa is
nitpicking everything unnecessarily do
you guys have the appetizer for table
five oh sorry we didn't give you that
yet no you did it
no no jonathan
is lost in the kitchen and service is
starting to suffer what table number is
this please that is table number 11 and
waiting on two flank steaks with it
where's the flank steak are they coming
uh moments moments uh minutes who's
cooking the flank steak come on guys we
can do one for top at the same time yes
yes i designed the menu around the size
of the kitchen the speed of both you
working together okay
come back for the flank what the hell is
this
look at me both yes both of you cut the
[ __ ] okay look at me you're more capable
of doing four [ __ ] main courses at
the same time especially when there's
two of you and one of those main courses
is the same dish we got to talk to each
other but i'm not gonna start sending
one dish at a time from four top serious
doesn't matter it doesn't matter at all
jonathan but look at me hey look at me i
need some [ __ ] effort from you a
little bit i need a little bit of
respect a little bit of effort from you
okay yeah and look at me you're the man
holding this [ __ ] thing together you
get it if you go down the whole [ __ ]
place is gonna go down so i need you to
step up okay i need your talk a little
bit and i want four main courses at the
same [ __ ] time
and jonathan yes you can get your mind
set round four main courses at the same
[ __ ] time
understand we're serving one table at
time and we're going to complete that
table yes four main courses three main
courses five main courses we're gonna
talk together yes it goes with what the
two soups what's coming next it's gonna
be uh
sausage two carrot soups and a fried
cheese sure for table seven okay so
we're talking now yep good carrot thank
you very much we have your flank steaks
your wine is coming right away okay
your sausage
you guys are all sharing right yeah yes
i think the new vienna will definitely
attract a younger crowd oh my gosh so
beautiful i'm super excited about the
new changes and i hope they'll last
i really do
uh right we've had ups and downs but
tonight is a prime example
of how good and how profitable this
business can be customers loving the
food they love the decor
i'm leaving with all the tools
to get this place back to where you
wanted to go
i do want to ask you one thing sure is
there anything that's happened this week
that you're not happy with yes i had
expected the bloom and zoomer to be done
not the konig but i was it was the room
i didn't expect
and the room that we've done is amazing
still has
problems can i just tell you something
really important this is not a makeover
show i know that yeah but you're
complaining about i wasn't saying i
didn't love that room it'd be a great
shame for you to sound ungrateful oh i'm
not ungrateful i am just strong
the news management system to dave uh
you've got no idea i'm gonna cross wrong
if you think that i'm being ungrateful
because i'm really not
it sounds like that
no
not at all i can't come in and wave a
magic wand and transform 15 bedrooms and
put a brand new kitchen you now know
what needs to happen i do but i need to
tell you something that you're not going
to like i arranged for a new stove you
did
to come
and then when i got the engineer to come
and survey the place
unfortunately he had to leave yeah
because he was going to shut the place
down
because there's practices that are
taking place in there that aren't
appropriate you're saying
the whole set up underneath there
nothing's been changed in 13 years
and it's on the verge of
running legally
listen i came here to help
but you need to help yourselves i need
to dig deep and stick together
okay
thank you thank you good luck okay keep
going okay
good night thank you
i'll feed you safe traveling
that's hard work
soon after i left lisa and jonathan
reverted to the old vienna this is
something
that belongs here
that came with the house
what are you doing
you're insane by changing the decor and
bringing back the original menu it's
worse than it was it looks horrible they
chose not to take my advice about
running the inn properly listen to me
about what should be going on in the
kitchen and as a result their reputation
in town remains the same
[Music]